en septiembre de 2020 un primer informe
emitido por la misión internacional
independiente de la onu para venezuela
instó al estado venezolano a exigir
cuentas a los responsables de crímenes
de lesa humanidad casi un año después un
segundo informe señala el sistema de
justicia venezolano como una parte del
problema
6 de acuerdo con los análisis e
investigaciones llevadas a cabo la
misión tiene suficientes motivos como
para creer que en vez de ofrecer
protección a las víctimas de violaciones
de derechos humanos y crímenes el
sistema de justicia venezolano ha jugado
un papel significativo en la represión
del estado contra opositores al gobierno
además la elaboración del informe se
basó en 177 entrevistas muchos actores
del sistema de justicia venezolano la
revisión de expedientes judiciales y
otros documentos oficiales así como el
análisis de la detención de unos 183
opositores muchas veces víctimas de
tortura o violencia sexual el documento
cita a un acusado que reveló la
aprehensión de sus familiares como
medida de presión los expertos aseguran
tener fundamentos razonables para
sospechar de la influencia de altos
actores políticos que ejerce presión
sobre los magistrados quienes incluso
recibirían órdenes sobre cómo deben
resolverse los juicios
hoy queda demostrado que la fiscalía el
ministerio público los tribunales y el
tribunal supremo de justicia han negado
la reparación la verdad y la justicia a
las víctimas y el estado venezolano no
castiga a las violaciones de derechos
humanos y no está en disposición de
hacerlo entre las conclusiones del
documento se presenta en 45
recomendaciones de acción urgente
dirigidas a entre otros organismos al
tribunal supremo de justicia defensoría
del pueblo asamblea nacional y poder
ejecutivo